هناك دول اوروبيه
قديمه
[موسيقى]
هذا المؤتمر اليوم ياتي
الدعم المقدم الاوكرانيا
وهذا الاجتماع
[موسيقى]
فمدي
معك اليوم سياده الرئيس الوزراء اليوم
مساء اليوم في فرنسا
لبحثي المساعدات الفرنسيه
للمساعدات الفرنسيه العاجله لاوكرانيا
اوكرانيا باشراف من الوزير الخارجيه
كاترين
او تاخذه
هنا الى ان الفا و800 من المجتمعات من
اعضاء المجتمع المدني قدموا مساعدات للشعب
الاوكراني
فقط وانما على كل شرائح المجتمع الفرنسيه
وانا اشكرهم جميعا
هذا المؤتمر
شفت فيها
دق دق
انت اليوم انت الان موجود في باريس بحضور
ضيوف دوليين
وهؤلاء الحاضرون
الحرب ايضا من اجل اوكرانيا اقول انه ان
ال ال
انهم يدافعون عن سياده اوكرانيا يجتمعون
هنا اليوم في باريس لدعم سياده اوكرانيا
نقطه البسه
شكرا
سياده الرئيس شكرا